hey what's up my name's tabulates and on
this video i wanted to talk about rent
to rent now I'm going to be going into
quite a lot of detail and went to rents
I recently posted a video it was like a
forty second summary video I punched it
on tik-tok and Instagram had thousands
and thousands of views and I had
hundreds of questions from people saying
but what about this and what about that
and what about the details and all sorts
of questions so I figured I would answer
all those questions and do a detailed
version of rent events here on YouTube
so first I'm gonna play the summary
version and then once you've seen the
summary version then I'm going to expand
and talk about still in the detail so
watch and enjoy let me explain to you a
strategy called rent to rent this is how
people make money from property without
even owning the property so instead of
buying this house this little three bed
two reception-room house they'll
actually just rent it and they'll pay
the landlord five into pounds a month
and instead of living in the house they
will rent out each room and they'll turn
the sitting room into a bedroom and they
went to each room for four hundred
pounds per month so four hundred times
four is sixteen hundred pounds now sure
they're gonna have to pay the landlord
five hundred pounds around and they're
gonna have to also pay the bills on the
property which might be four hundred
pound but that's gonna leave a cash flow
of eight hundred pounds per month on a
property that I do not even own that is
rent to rent I literally just hit that
impromptu I said the profit was 800 that
was my bad math it was actually seven
hundred not many people surprisingly
picked up on that but what they did pick
up on was lots of other things so the
first thing that people said is isn't
this subletting isn't this illegal and
the answer to that is no it is not
illegal rent to rent has not a new thing
it's been around for years it's
something that's very very commonly
accepted in commercial property in
businesses all this is it is a business
agreement on a residential property so
as long as you use the right agreement
if you use an AST contract and then just
select it then that is illegal but if
you use a correct contract and that is a
management agreement a corporate left
and tell the landlord what you're doing
it is perfectly legal the second thing
that got asked a lot
people said is they said but Samuel to
do what you just suggested on the scrap
of paper you would need a license
because it's a HMO and HMOs need
licenses it was surprising how many
people said this you were even letting
agents and people that were apparently
experienced in property because is they
you do not need a hey CH mo license
unless there are five or more tenants in
the property so my example that I
sketched out with four tenants that
would not need a license now this does
vary slightly from counsel to counsel
but the standard rule of thumb is that
your only need HMO license if the
property has five or more people now you
still will need fire doors and smoke
alarms to keep it safe but you will not
need a license nor will you need any
kind of rent to rent license in order to
carry out a renter and deal the third
question that came up was planning
permission people said to change the use
of a single letter into a multi layer
you need planning permission again this
is just not the case
you only need planning permission if the
HMO has got seven or more people in the
property or if it's in an article 4 area
you will need to check with the council
to see what the rules are on this
because some councils have strange rules
such as Oxford however you can do that
on a very special website which is G 0 G
L e Google if you just google what the h
mo rules are in a particular area you'll
be able to see whether you need planning
permission or whether you need a license
and generally speaking for the example
that I did on the scrap of paper you
will not need either for question that
came up which is about the mortgage now
if there is a mortgage on the property
and you're turning a buy-to-let into a
HMO well you need permission from the
lender now it might be that the lender
has restrictions on turning it into a
multi let if there are restrictions from
the from the lender then you will need
to ask the lenders permission this is
just general standard practice in
property investing if you're going to
rent something out you need permission
to do that and if you're going to rent
out in a peculiar way such as serviced
accommodation or buy the room on
HM oh of course you're going to need to
make sure that the lending on the
property is fit for purpose with what
you actually do with the property the
fifth thing that came up and this was
one of the this is one of the most
common ones people were saying but
Samuel what if you can't rent out the
rooms and then you're stuck and you took
on a property and now you've got to pay
the landlord and you can't even rent it
out and most bonds to that is well
that's that's the importance of due
diligence and market research you're not
going to take on a property unless
you're confident you're going to rent
the rooms out and if you do take on a
property and you can't rent the rooms
out then thank God you didn't buy the
property see it as an experience I mean
when people say vector rents really
risky and really hard because you might
not be able to rent the rooms out and
there's the tech problems of the tenants
and all this stuff I'm thinking well
surely if you're going to argue that
then you're just going to say that
property in general is risky and the
truth is if you do it wrong yes it's
hard you can have problems with tenants
you can buy properties in the wrong area
and you can't rent them out as much as
you thought and that's why it's really
important to get the correct training
and went to rent is a really good way of
actually getting experience with
property without necessarily having to
buy a property sixth question is well
who and her as a landlord would let a
amateur newbie take on their property as
a renter and guaranteed to give them
around if this amateur person doesn't
know what they're doing this is
something that a lot of people were
saying as well and I think the answer to
that is of course there's going to be
some landlords that wouldn't
there's going to be some that would and
it's just a case they've been able to
get the skills to be able to be
confident and competent when you're
speaking to the landlord if you've gone
through a training program and you know
what to say how to check an area how to
speak to people that's going to put you
head and shoulders above people that are
just having a batch also one of the
reasons I advocate training programs is
because I've seen firsthand i've
experiences myself and i've seen this
with many other of my students is you'll
have student over here who's got a large
property portfolio and he's wanted to
scale up and get into
development and then you've got student
over here who's wanted to get into rent
events he's got no money
he's got no properties and these two
actually meet up on the training program
and this person passes this person a rep
one of his properties on a renter end so
this person's a newbie but if they're in
the right place at the right time and
educating themselves and confident and
learning what to say and how to speak
well of course it's possible
and there are landlords to pass on their
properties to newbies as long as those
newbies are investing in themselves are
educating themselves and know the crack
number eight and this is another
objection which people say about rent
events and they send this they say that
it is not passive it's not passive
income listen okay firstly it can be
passive because if you take on rent to
rent so then you employ somebody to
manage the whole thing that is passive
however if you're managing it yourself
which you probably will be when you
start off with it might not be passive
you're gonna need to manage it you're
gonna need to deal with tenants but it's
still income and if you haven't got lots
of money to start with and you're
starting from scratch getting some
rental properties and making five
hundred seven hundred one thousand
pounds a month from a property you don't
own even if it's not completely passive
it's still in my opinion pretty good
going I mean you might have seen on
windows Wednesday a lady called Stella
she came on with my channel just about a
month ago she's making four and a half
thousand pounds profit a month and she's
doing that on top of her full-time job
with rent to rent so is it passive
probably not completely passive but is
it worth looking at a hundred percent
yes which leads me to my last question
which is is it worth doing is it worth
the trouble and listen that just depends
on you if you have got a job that's
paying you three thousand pounds a month
and you know that five rent to rent
properties could replace that and you're
just desperate to get out of your job
and you itching to get into property and
get your hands dirty you prepared to
work hard then it probably is worth two
minutes friends if you don't want to get
your hands dirty don't want to work hard
and have a very low risk appetite and
are happy to stay in a job there maybe
it's not worth doing it
depends on you as a person but went to
write as a strategy and as a tool is
certainly a very feasible tool and it
does work for lots lots of people if you
do it right I hope you guys enjoyed this
video let me know your thoughts on
rental rates below drop a comment Austin
if you've got a question about rent to
rent you like answering drop a comment
drop a question below don't forget to
smash the like button if you enjoyed the
video and also if you watch my video
you're not subscribed turn on them to
subscribe button turn on the
notification bow as it going to be
something absolutely awesome videos
coming up very soon thanks so much for
watching peace out I'll see you next
time